[Musique]
voilà quand on a un sujet compliqué
d'avoir le talent d'un grand parti ç'a
permis à dire des choses en peu de temps
qui viennent nous rejoindre langage
universel et ce mariage universel il est
aussi ravi au service d'un parcours de
vie un parcours de vie qui est qui n'est
pas choisie et sur lequel le monde
la société invite dit portion de la
population
ce parcours de vie moi je les franchit à
dix neuf ans à une époque où mon
quotidien et essuie d'étudiants qui
avaient à une génération où on se posait
pas la question de l'empreinte carbone
où on avait essentiellement l'objectif
de bien réussir avec une efficacité
économique de la reconnaissance créer
une entreprise c'était l'époque voilà
bernard tapie etc
et puis un matin à 5 heures du matin et
bien un coup de fil à la maison j'étais
seul j'étais un stage et ses coups de
fil là une seconde avant tout va bien le
quotidien et celui qu'ils ont choisi
qu'on croit pouvoir choisir et maîtriser
sa vie et ils seront après tout
s'écroule
j'ai appris ce jour là que ma soeur qui
avait deux ans de menthe mois 17 ans
passagère d'une voiture la veille
la voiture avait pris le l'arbre à 80
km/heure et que cécile était dans le
coma entre la vie et la mort un an avant
cécile serait décédé qu'est ce qui s'est
passé là notre société française a fait
un choix absolument fascinant dont on ne
mesure je pense toujours pas bien un
pacte qui est de mailler le territoire
pour que en 17 minutes en moyenne
partout en france 24 heures sur 24 365
jours par an si on est sujet d'un grave
accident
les accidents de la route sinon du sport
après 40 45 ans avec le stress la
sédentarité la malbouffe
les accidents vasculaires cérébraux et
bien qu'on puisse être maintenue en vie
alors on voit là une belle promesse mais
on sait avec maintenant 40 ans de recul
que lorsqu'on se réveille après des
semaines des mois de coma eh bien ces
personnes quarante mille personnes
chaque année en france
ça impacte directement toute une famille
c'est à dire deux cent mille personnes
depuis 40 ans a fait 8 millions de
français un peu plus d'un français sur
dix eh bien on sait que ces personnes se
réveillent avec des lésions dans le
cerveau et ses lésions du cerveau fait
quand on devient un peu champion du
monde du handicap des lésions qui crée
du handicap physique plus du handicap
cognitif plusieurs handicaps sensoriels
et enfin du handicap psychique et alors
on vient à ce moment là interrogé par la
parole ou le regard de celui ou de celle
qui se réveille les questions
fondamentales qu'on a du mal à se poser
au quotidien qu'on a du mal ou con qu'on
élude parce qu'elles sont compliquées
qui est la question de ckoi ma vie qui
est l'être humain quelle quel est le
sens de ma vie et c'est d'un long voyage
dans lequel on est à ce moment là en mai
et c'est un voyage assez radical
exigeant et ce voyage
paradoxalement me passionne parce que
c'était un voyage dans lequel je pense
qu'on peut trouver une question clé aux
grands défis civilisationnel que l'on
est confronté aujourd'hui
autrement dit si pour le plus petit si
pour le plus fragile si pour le plus
dépendant à sa rencontre
il nous amène à trouver des éléments de
réponse à cette question du sens de la
vie
alors peut-être peut-être que chacun
nous on va retrouver l'espoir d'une
société dans lequel on peut tout
place alors c'est un incroyable défi un
incroyable défi parce que cette personne
quand elle se réveille elle nous dit
elle dit à la société je résume avec mes
mots mais pourquoi tu as mis des
milliards chaque année pour nous garder
en vie alors que depuis que je suis
enfant quand j'étais honoré dans le
vente et dans les bras d'un moment
j'étais en communion c'était ball
l'amour mais dès que j'étais à l'école
la maman a dû ouvrir le bras hélas son
doigt et tenter de se tendre pour
regarder le carnet de notes et
insidieusement on se construit on
construit notre identité dans une
société qui nous dit pour être pour
réussir il faut surclassé l'autre la vis
ta vie aura du sens si tu efficace si tu
es rentable si tu apprends bien si tu
gagnes de l'argent si tu peux si tu
parais etc etc
or la personne handicapée par ses
traumatismes ces accidents vasculaires
cérébraux et se réveille se trouve
confronté à une situation pour la
majorité d'entre elles qui est
extraordinairement compliquée puisque ce
sont des personnes qui ont une très
bonne mémoire d'avant l'accident et qui
n'ont pas de mémoire de ce qu'ils ont
fait les dix minutes
ces personnes si on les imagine si on
nous nous imaginons dans leur situation
une part de nous est tenté de dire
est-ce que leur vie vaut la peine d'être
vécue
et là on peut plus être dans des
considérations romantique aux
séduisantes ou marc fesneau
on est confronté à l'épicentre du réel
et on est comme convoqué dans une
question fondamentale que les
philosophes appellent la question autres
pots logique qui est l'inscription de
savoir qui est l'être humain est ce que
cette question n'est pas essentielle
est-ce que construire sa vie construire
un quotidien qui a du sens ça passe pas
par le courage de se confronter à cette
question de qui est l'homme dans
l'histoire de l'humanité on vit un
moment très particulier il ya eu 130
milliards d'êtres humains sur terre
depuis le début de l'humanité jusqu'à il
ya peu on était membre d'une communauté
très local s'attribue puis son village
et donc il y avait quelque chose d'une
finitude
il y avait quelque chose d'une maîtrise
nous sommes tous à une époque
vertigineuse de promesses et belles
quiétude qui est une époque où notre
village devient de village monde et où
on voit dans une dans une abrogation de
l'espace et du temps souvent très
virtuel mais on voit de telles
différences des questions tellement
immense au quotidien souvent à travers
nos écrans que l'on est psychiquement
dans une situation où on pourrait
presque dire que notre capacité d'action
devient inversement proportionnel à la
taille de notre communauté
autrement dit quand ma communauté des
tribal villageoise quelques centaines ou
milliers de personnes je pouvais à j
qui suis-je aujourd'hui pour agir dans
une société de 9 milliards d'êtres
humains et il y à cela un coût psychique
qui à mon sens explique beaucoup de l'
angoisse individuelle et collective que
vit notre société et c'est très
intéressant de se poser la question est
ce que finalement ce n'est pas un grand
projet de société que de penser que
c'est peut-être le plus fragile qui peut
nous emmener par la main pour nous aider
à cheminer vers une réponse
la question n'est pas simple je suis
convaincu que nos deux grands défis
le grand défi d'être humain quand on se
pose cette question du qui est l'homme
le grand défi d'être humain c'est ont le
talent est évoqué tout à l'heure le défi
de la peur mais peut-être pas d'abord de
la peur de l'autre
peut-être d'abord de la peur de soi même
quelle est cette peur insidieuse
cette perte de soi même elle vient se
nicher dans des questions qui peuvent
faire mal qu'ils aient le sentiment
insidieux de risquer de ne pas être
éligible ou de ne plus être éligible
dans ce système de valeurs qui peut
évidemment que c'est bon d'être bien
formé dans une bonne école évidemment
que c'est heureux d'avoir une belle
carrière mais si je fais de ses
objectifs
un absolu de ma vie à ce moment là cet
objectif devient tyrannique
si la finalité c'est la performance
je suis insidieusement en permanence en
angoisse intérieur de ne pas être
éligibles au de ne plus être éligible et
si je crois que mon système de valeurs
m'amène à la performance comme système
absolue à ce moment là effectivement
tous ceux qui vont moins vite qu'ils
sont plus faibles ou qui sont plus
fragiles ou qui sont différents il faut
les éliminer celles de rappel des pages
assez sombre de l'histoire
alors on peut se dire où met-on curseur
à quel niveau de fragilité on devient
éligible et vous savez c'est intéressant
parce que on est dans un pays où sur les
frontons de nos mairies
il ya une valeur commune qui s'appelle
la fraternité est ce que cette valeur de
la fraternité auquel on aspire tous on
sait bien quelque chose de bon mais
c'est une valeur qui est trop précieuse
pour être défendable
uniquement l'égalité la liberté ça se
défend dans un tribunal la fraternité
c'est trop précieux pour faire se
défendre devant un tribunal
c'est notre part de liberté individuelle
et collective et sept valeurs de
fraternité
si je la conjugue au regard de cette
quête de la performance
alors ne risque-t-elle pas de devenir
fratricide
sinon absolue de ma vie c'est
l'efficacité la performance de savoir le
pouvoir le valoir et c'est à ce moment
là l'autre est une menace
parce qu'il risque un jour d'être on
sait bien ou alors je risque un jour de
ne plus pouvoir alors et les chemins de
la fraternité et bien l'expérience que
je vis depuis ce coup de fil
et puis après un parcours d'entrepreneur
de chefs d'entreprises depuis 15 ans je
me suis promis de mettre mon ce que j'ai
appris comme chef d'entreprise j'ai une
entreprise avec 70 consultants rejoint
un groupe anglo saxons j'ai vendu etc
je suis dit mais en fait ça va être
passionnant de mettre ces savoirs au au
profit de cette question tous partagent
ce soir mais je mens je pensais que ça
allait prendre trois quatre ans ça fait
quinze ans que ça dure parce que la
fragilité nous mettant du temps non et
on est dans un aussi dans une société
qui nous est seul parce qu'elle ne veut
dans une immédiateté immédiate et de la
performance et de la réussite
or profondément on a besoin de temps
dont suffit de regarder les cycles de la
nature
alors cette fraternité
elle a été un chemin tu es passé par ces
mois de coma et puis après ça ces années
où et c'est vrai quand on a une
quelqu'un qu'on aime qui est handicapé
mais c'est vrai aussi quand on fait le
deuil de quelqu'un qu'on aime c'est vrai
quand on a confronté une maladie grave
a insi part à une séparation à des
situations douloureuses de 2,2
de solitude ou ou d'exil 1 pour des gens
qui doivent quitter leur pays qui est en
rien etc
et bien en fait ça nous amène d'abord un
état de sidération et mon expérience
depuis maintenant 15 ans et qu'on peut
pas accélérer ce moment là quand vous
avez des proches des gens vous aimez
autour de vous qui vit ces douloureux
moments là ces coups de fil
cette seconde avant cette seconde
d'après ne prenez pas l'attitude du
french doctor qui veut vite réglé le
problème
je pense que danser ce moment-là
considérer l'autre c'est simplement
prendre le temps d'être là et cet
étonnant d'ailleurs parce que le verbe
est un verbe d'état ils nous rappellent
peut-être un élément de réponse à cette
question anthropologique que nous sommes
des êtres humains comme il est bon de se
mettre au rythme de 7 personnes fragiles
différentes affaibli handicapés qui nous
amène à décélérer aspen dans ce temps
long et cette personne là il faut cinq
ans huit en dix ans pour comme changer
le le disque dur intégré ces lésions
cérébrales ces handicaps divers et
parfois il faut comme touché de fond de
la piscine pour avoir l'énergie pour
rebondir et ce rebond là c'est lequel
c'est lorsque la personne fragile
parvient à faire le deuil de sa vie
d'avant je vous évoqué dans les
handicaps le handicap psychique
qu'est ce que c'est le psychique le psy
chic ça va chercher du côté de la psyché
la psyché c'est lam lam c qui suis-je
cette question qu'on nous passe poser
cette question spirituelle qui est
l'être humain étonnant de ré ouvrir un
espace de liberté cette question là dans
ces moments de fragilité
et comme si ces personnes fragiles
étaient des prophètes qui nous ramenait
cette espèce de ballon d'oxygène
prenons temps de savoir qui on est
et je vous évoquez cette peur peur - de
moi-même paires de pattes éligibles à ce
moment là au bout de ces années là
personnes fragiles arrive à un moment où
elle va quand même faire le deuil de qui
elle était pour ouvrir une capacité
d'une puissance extraordinaire qui est
la capacité de dire à l'autre de dire à
chacun d'eux dans nos familles dans
notre cour d'immeuble dans nos
entreprises nos écoles
une des phrases les plus puissantes du
monde qui te dire à l'autre j'ai besoin
de toi
on est dans une société où on apprend à
admirer les gens qui traversent le monde
en solitaire sans avoir besoin des
autres en tant que chef d'entreprise
j'ai appris pendant des années avoir
besoin des autres et à créer un
collectif capable ensemble dans
l'interdépendance dans une fragilité
conjuguées de créer de l'intelligence et
de la créativité collective
et lorsque cette personne fragile me dit
j'ai besoin de toi
elle vient fissurer en moi ce mur de la
peur sept personnes fragiles vient
fissurer en moi la peur de ne pas être
éligibles puisqu'elles laurent éligibles
elle le rend capable tout d'un coup
cette personne me donner le goût de
l'autre elle belle quelle belle
espérance quand même le goût de l'autre
et ce goût de l'autre il va nous faire
découvrir de promesses
la première promesse c'est que quand
quelqu'un me dit j'ai besoin de toi tout
seul je peux pas y arriver avec mon
corps fragile tout de suite sa demande
devient une promesse la promesse de
quand je te lis j'ai besoin de toi je te
fais confiance je mets mon corps fragile
entre des mains et on a beaucoup de
jeunes qui devait faire une allée de
volontariat service civique dans nos
maisons
on a aujourd'hui 30 maisons à travers la
france
un système qui se duplique par essaimage
et les jeunes qui pourraient partir en
voyage humanitaire qui pourrait partir
ailleurs soulagée mais pourquoi tu es là
je ferai un jour m'a dit ça fait quatre
ans que je me cherchais ici je me suis
trouvée isabelle m'a dit c'est la
première fois j'ai 21 ans c'est la
première fois qu'on me fait vraiment
confiance
ce qui nous permet de cheminer avec ce
peuple fragile en disant est ce que vous
n'êtes pas vous les prophètes d'une
société d'espérance
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas vous les
prophètes un grand projet de société
dans lequel vous n'aurez à prôner non
pas le premier de cordée mais celui qui
est au coeur qui crée cette société de
confiance qui crée cette société n'ont
pas traduisible et fraternel qui
développe cette intelligence collective
qui développe cette confiance collective
et pour ceux d'entre vous qui fait des
études de commerce
vous savez combien les économistes nous
disent que la confiance c'est le
prérequis de la croissance est là on
parle pas uniquement d'une croissance
économique dans le parc du 300 sumène on
parle d'une vision de l'homme où tout
d'un coup on s'est dit mais si le plus
fragile me fait confiance
il vient me libérer de la peur de à jour
ne plus être éligible il vient
construire un projet de société comme
j'aurais toujours ma place il ya
construit un projet qui me fait du bien
et c'est bon parce que c'est parfois on
a une espèce de d'ainsi dieuze
culpabilité le dire mais est-ce que j'ai
vraiment droit de faire du
bien mon expérience assez mondial c'est
que c'est pas droit c'est une nécessité
pour être heureux de se faire du bien et
quand contre c'est du bien soit eh bien
on fait du bien à l'autre quand on ose
cette relation de confiance et jeux
extraordinaires que c'est dire que cette
école de la vie c'est l'école des plus
fragiles qui d'entre nous n'a pas fait
l'expérience de sa grand-mère âgée avec
qui les mots ne sont plus présents et on
est on passe d'une communication qui
peut parfois être difficile on n'ose pas
se regarder on sait pas quoi se dire à
une communion de deux êtres qui
simplement se tiennent la main qui n'a
pas été bouleversé par ces écrites ces
derniers instants de vie de demain qui
tienne pour le passage qui n'a pas été
bouleversée je suis grand père depuis
trois mois c'est parce j'ai eu la chance
de donner le biberon ma petite fille
j'ai puisé dans cette est le plus
fragile qui soit une espèce de deux
réservoirs de paix intérieure pour ma
journée et j penseurs recevront je
devrais vous en parler ce soir en me
disant mais finalement dans notre
espérance de vie de 80 82 ans on dit
maintenant est ce qu'il n'est pas temps
de revisiter le fait que les 25
premières années de notre vie nous
racontons pas d'histoires on est fragile
salle teddy différemment tout au long de
la soirée
notre quotidien est incertain notre
avenir est une promesse risque et
combien les 25 dernières années de notre
vie on se re fragilise
ça fait quand même déjà 50 ans de
fragilité sur 80 ans d'espérance de vie
et combien sur les trente ans milieu 8
millions de chômeurs ou d'emploi fragile
dix millions de personnes handicapées
une rupture affective sur deux est ce
qu'il n'est pas temps de se réconcilier
avec sa fragilité
alors je vous en partage de clés la
première clé c'est la clé du silence
paul claudel disait le 20e siècle est le
siècle du bruit est une conspiration
contre le silence
je pense que le plus beau cadeau qu'on
puisse se faire au début de sa journée
c'est de prendre le temps de l'artiste
le temps de l'artiste s'étant de
l'intériorité le temps de faire silence
pour écouter jaillir en soit ses
aspirations ses désirs ses peurs et
trouver cette énergie vitale qui va nous
guider pour oser être humain ensemble
oser se laisser happer par le sdf par le
la personne handicapée par l'étudiant un
peu seul au bout du couloir
30% des jeunes est une sofres ont peur
de la solitude
une personne sur deux dans nos grandes
villes vivent seules
en 2050 80 % de l'humanité david dans
des grandes villes
sur les dix milliards ça veut dire car à
4 milliards de personnes seules est-ce
qu'il n'est pas temps de chacun est qu
acteur d'une société où on se laisse
prendre et emmenée par la main par les
plus fragiles et cette promesse on peut
tous là partagé parce que c'est plus
fragiles son tour de nous ils nous
appellent et nous font confiance
[Applaudissements]